-Let's get to the news.
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
appeared last night
at the Grammy Awards.
It was gonna be Joe,
but he's not trusted
with classified material.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set
tomorrow to deliver
his State of the Union Address,
and it's not a great sign
that the best he can say is,
"The state of our union
is balloon-free."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden told reporters
over the weekend
that he ordered the military
to shoot down the suspected
Chinese spy balloon, which
must've been tough,
'cause if anyone loves balloons,
it's this guy.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report
from Bloomberg News,
New York Congressman
George Santos
once claimed to have been a
producer on the Broadway musical
"Spider-Man: Turn off the Dark".
Another obvious lie,
because if you saw that show,
you know it didn't have
producers.
[ Laughter ]
At an event at the White House
last week,
celebrating
the 30th anniversary of the
Family and Medical Leave Act,
former President Bill Clinton
said that he has more people
bring up this law than,
"any other specific thing
he did."
Well, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like it's the second.
That's like OJ saying
most people bring up
his Hertz commercials.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Canada are
searching for two suspects
who were seen driving
a stolen car
through a shopping mall.
Whoa!
If it was the '90s,
they could've killed someone.
[ Laughter ]
It's such a fancy
abandoned mall.
According to a new study,
Florida, last year,
experienced more lightning
strikes than any other state,
which might mean that even God
is getting tired of waiting
for Merrick Garland.
[ Laughter ]
The Rock & Roll Hall of Fame has
announced this year's
class of nominees.
It's the one hall of fame
that understands
that performance-enhancing drugs
are just part of the game.
[ Laughter ]
A federal judge in Oklahoma
recently ruled
that a law prohibiting marijuana
users from owning guns
is unconstitutional.
It makes sense, because by
the time they find their gun,
they forgot what
they were mad about.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have released
a trailer for a new reality show
about actor Sylvester Stallone
and his family.
And, yeah, you're probably gonna
need the captions on.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Cambodia recently
built a home
modeled after an airplane,
and now he's finally
ready to sit back, relax,
and recline his armchair
three inches.
And finally, in honor
of Valentine's Day,
the restaurant chain
Cracker Barrel has launched
a new contest that'll give five
couples free food for a year
if they get engaged
at the restaurant.
Also, doing a promotion
for newly engaged couples
at Cracker Barrel --
divorce attorneys.
[ Laughter ]
Bless your heart,
but take a card just in case.
President Biden delivered
his second
State of the Union Address
tonight.
Oh, you mean his balloon
assassination victory lap?
[ Laughter ]
"You know who would
love some inflation?
That spy balloon, bitch."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"But seriously, yeah, eggs are
really expensive right now."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the
State of the Union was tonight,
and U2's Bono attended
as a guest
of First Lady Dr. Jill Biden.
And I got to say,
I love that she's using
the office of first lady
to tick off her bucket list.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, she was at the Grammys.
She's going to the Super Bowl.
Now, she's hanging out
with Bono.
If Biden gets reelected,
she's going to get
the old gang together
for one last heist.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden posted several
photos yesterday to Instagram.
Not on purpose.
He was trying
to answer his phone and kept
hitting the wrong button.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden tweeted
a picture yesterday
of the first page of his
State of the Union Address
and I got to say, I'm surprised
how he's kicking things off.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
The Pentagon said yesterday that
the military failed to detect
three Chinese spy balloons
over the continental U.S.
during the Trump administration
due to a "awareness gap"
and because, after the eclipse,
Trump wasn't allowed to look
in the sky anymore.
[ Laughter ]
The first public beach is set
to open this summer
in Manhattan,
along the Hudson River,
so, if you see
some beach bodies,
there's a good chance
they washed up there.
[ Laughter ]
"Yellowstone" actor
Kevin Costner
is reportedly considering
leaving the series
to focus on directing
a new film.
Said your dad, "But, you know,
other than that, I'm fine.
Alright, here's your mom."
[ Laughter ]
A dog in Nevada
was recently rescued
after living with a pack
of coyotes for several months.
Fortunately,
the dog is now safe, sound,
and embittered for life.
"I was living the dream!"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, the FAA yesterday
proposed fining United Airlines
more than $1 million
for skipping safety steps.
Even worse, Spirit put
black electrical tape
over the check engine light.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden delivered
his 2nd State of the Union
Address last night.
And spoke for 73 minutes
which sounds like a lot.
But I feel like Biden
could speak for 73 minutes
to a wrong number.
"Well -- Well,
who were you trying to reach?
Let's try to figure
this out together."
New York Representative
George Santos
was reportedly one of the first
members of Congress
to arrive for last night's
State of the Union.
He wanted a good seat.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I -- but I think I am.
I think I am the President."
Last night's
State of the Union
was the first time
since 2019 that the event
was held without
coronavirus restrictions.
And in case
you're wondering
who in that room
never reads their e-mails.
[ Laughter ]
"For your information,
this isn't a COVID mask,
this is just for dander."
[ Laughter ]
"Very allergic."
During the speech last night,
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
wore a white fur coat
in the House chamber.
And bad news guys --
that was our last one.
[ Laughter ]
She looked great.
It was --
I think we all agree
it was worth it.
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
posted a video to Twitter
yesterday showing herself
trying to bring a large
white balloon
as a guest
to the State of the Union.
And you know, I didn't know
who she'd bring as a guest,
but I knew they'd be white.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said
last night some Republicans
are threatening to repeal
the Inflation Reduction Act.
And added, "As my
football coach used to say,
'Lot's of luck
in your senior year.'"
But take that
with a grain of salt
because his coach
also used to say,
"One day this game
will be played with helmets."
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of last night's speech,
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
reportedly told Republican
lawmakers
to be on their best behavior.
"Fine! I'll put the safety on,"
said Lauren Boebert.
[ Laughter ]
Zoom CEO Eric Yuan yesterday
announced plans to cut staff.
And said he will reduce
his own salary by 98%.
Making him the only person
that can legitimately claim
that the vaccine
made his life worse.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to a new
study 18% of Americans
use a sleep medication.
Whereas, the others prefer to
fall asleep the traditional way,
reliving every awkward moment
of their lives.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today,
traveled to Florida
and spoke about
Social Security and Medicare.
He didn't intend to, it's just
what everybody in Florida
was already talking about.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Congressman
James Clyburn praised
President Biden's State of the
Union performance yesterday
and said Biden displayed,
"The kind of maturity
that the American people would
like to see in a president."
When you say maturity,
you mean this guy?
[ Laughter ]
You're talking about this guy?
I think that's the maturity you
expect from your cool uncle.
"Hey, hop in kid.
We're gonna go to
Dave and Busters.
I got a bucket
full of quarters."
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer praised
President Biden yesterday
for baiting Republicans
into a bi-partisan agenda during
the State of the Union Address
and said, "He let
them walk into his trap."
Alright, that might be
a little generous.
It's more like
when someone falls
running away from Michael Myers.
Was it a trap?
Or did Michael Myers
just get lucky?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Schumer said Biden
let them walk into his trap
while Marjorie Taylor Greene
let a seal walk into hers.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
yesterday defended her
heckling of President Biden
during the State of the Union
and said,
"I don't clap for liars."
Well, whatever she claps for,
it's definitely on the
ones and threes.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
For the people who got it,
I think they're gonna
like it a great deal.
[ Laughter ]
Do I think both you and I knew,
Baze, that wasn't
for everybody,
but for the people it was for --
Fred, did you like it?
-Oh yes.
-Yeah, there you go, see?
Some of these jokes
are for drummers.
[ Laughter ]
North Korean leader
Kim Jong Un
was joined on stage yesterday
by his 9-year-old daughter
at a military parade unveiling
the country's new missiles.
So, I guess
bring-your-daughter-to-work day
has officially
jumped the shark.
[ Laughter ]
New York Congressman Nick Lalota
Referred to fellow
Republican representative
George Santos during
an interview yesterday as
a "sociopath"
which ironically is the only
thing not on his resume.
[ Laughter ]
Ukrainian President Zelenskyy
met with King Charles yesterday
at Buckingham palace.
"How's the war going,"
asked Zelenskyy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Fire fighters in -- we should
say right now -- you know what,
this joke is very dependent
on a graphic.
We haven't seen it yet.
We're gonna find out in real
time if this joke pays off.
[ Laughter ]
I think
in the writing of the joke,
he had a very clear idea
of what it was gonna look like,
and now we're gonna find out.
Fire fighters in Pennsylvania
were recently called to remove
a cake pan that got stuck
on a girl's head.
And right before picture day.
[ Audience "aws," laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
I guess you can win them all.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities in
Texas arrested a man this week
who they believe broke into
the Dallas zoo
and stole two monkeys.
Though when reached for comment,
the man was, you guessed it,
already busted out
by two monkeys.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
♪♪